When I was a kid I used to live in a haunted apartment and I would always complain to my
mom about all these creepy things happening around the place but she always thought I
was making it up to this day.
The only story she actually believes is one where she was also there with me.
I was sleeping in her bed with her one night and my arm was hanging off the side of the
bed.
Bad idea.
When suddenly a big dark creepy hand crept up from under the bed and grabbed mine and
pulled on me.
I was too sleepy and stupid brained so all I did was open my eyes, stare at it, ripped
my hand out of its grasp and roll over and went back to sleep.
I would not have had those same balls to do that today.
I don't know what I was thinking.